as kopit 19 cases continue to climb
health officials are urging people to
mask up
while indoors in public but are people
really making the change
joe mueller spoke to some shoppers and
business owners
about what they are noticing and he
joins us live near desert inn and
decatur with those reactions joe
christian we're going in a direction
that nobody really wants to go in and
having to put these masks
back on while indoors out in public some
people say they're not really
noticing much of a difference when they
do go out in public but they are
noticing
more employees wearing masks now cases
are on the rise here in clark county
much higher than they have been the past
few months
this pushed the health district to
recommend people wear those masks and
doors
on the strip some hotels are making
changes for employees to wear masks
owner of boss security screens off the
strip is making employees wear masks
when customers are around
well i did talk to a few people who were
shopping today at walmart in the
southwest valley they did not notice
more people wearing them i think it's
actually less less people are actually
wearing masks
people are not wearing a mask they don't
care it's just people don't care
i mean i don't know if they're watching
the news or if they're really paying
attention to what's going on
and we took this topic to social media
and asked people how they are feeling
about this we first asked if people
are using the mast again indoors more
than 50 percent of people said
that they are we also asked people if
they feel safer with these
new recommendations that came out less
than half after actually say they feel
any different they don't feel any more
safe now
than they did last week with these new
recommendations reporting live at di
indicator joe mullen 8 news now